All right, welcome to everybody to another Monday Zoom call.
Thank you everybody that is setting in questions on the member site that is the proper way to do things.
We do have to ask that people stop emailing questions. They're just legal issues with emailing questions and emailing answers back.
We have to keep things to a Zoom call platform.
So that's just my lead with you. So if you're could use to emailing questions, I know it's a change. You're going to get an email back that time.
We'll just tell you what I'm telling you right now, but please address your questions on this. You can keep them as general as possible. And as you see, what do we get to your questions?
I don't know anybody's name. So, um, there, but also remember your you have access to all the courses. So make sure you can look up those two.
Utilize your member site. Again, these are the courses that you have available to you. All right. So I want to cover this question. I did cover it last week, but I do want to cover it again because I know there's some clarification there may need to take place.
Um, with, um, Elklyn phosphatase, whatever I said, Elklyn phosphatase, um, where that is elevated, um, there are concerns. So the different possibilities of elevated Elklyn phosphatase.
What I'm going to mention can be metastasis to the bone. If there's a lidic metastasis to the bone, it can raise Elklyn phosphatase levels.
Now, if your Elklyn phosphatase is 115, that's usually not a giant red flag of metastasis to the bone. Usually it goes way up to 250 or something like that with body metastasis.
More likely, just, um, congestion in the liver, um, it can be metastasis to the level liver, too. It's, it understands it's an indiscriminate test.
It can give us clues to different things just like so many things in our blood work.
Um, that's what they do. They give us clues. They don't tell us exactly what's going on.
Even with a low red blood cell count, which is that mean you have anemia. Well, yes, but doesn't tell you why you have anemia.
Would you have anemia from an ulcer that's bleeding? Yes. Could you have anemia from a tumor that's on the X outside of your body that's bleeding.
Loss of blood. Could you have bleeding because you have really heavy periods? That's could be the reason why you have mild anemia.
Um, could you have bleeding? Could you have a loss of red blood cells, low, low chemotherapy? Because a cancer is gobbled up iron? Yes.
We don't want to jump to the worst case scenario. We just want to use the blood work as giving us clues.
So, uh, so that's with all your blood work. It's giving us clues that we're talking about cancer markers in a second.
Same thing with any testing. It gives you clues. You have to balance it with other objective and subjective findings to remember that.
So it also I want to encourage you guys. I know there are some of you that are other sense about using standards of care or incorporating standards of care. Maybe chemotherapy, maybe surgery into your protocol.
We're not discouraging you for doing that. That is not our position. That is not our place. That's beyond our scope of our practice.
And I really, you know, I know, I know some of you want, you know, most people want to be told what to do with me. That's just kind of human nature.
Just tell me what to do. I just want to be told what to do.
But we're not going to do that. So, um, the reason we're not going to do that is because I, you know, multiple reasons.
Number one, we can't tell you what to do from a medical standard of care approach, because that would be, you know, practicing medicine without a license that would be going beyond our scope of practice.
But also, I don't think it's ethical. I don't think it's more. I think, you know, we're going to be good coaches for you. We need to push that responsibility back on you.
You don't want an oncologist telling you what to do. You don't want a natural doctor telling you what to do. You want people giving you proper options.
You weigh that out and you go into the Lord and prayer. You want to be obedient to him.
Um, and if you don't have a relationship with him, way to know which way he's leading you that allow the difficulties in life to help you grow that relationship.
So that you do and are able to have that, that type of relationship with him so that you know the other shadow of a doubt.
Really what you're supposed to do. Um, so you weigh that out. You go to the Lord with those questions and you, you seek him until you get an answer.
The other question we have come across in the last week.
Uh, some info on that relates cancer with lights.
Sorry.
It's a Lyme disease that Lyme disease just remember with Lyme and parasites.
So that is possibility. So a person can have Lyme disease, person can have coal infections with Lyme, person can have parasites can affect cancer. Yes.
Are you doing more parasite programs? Should we continue this pre and post surgery? Yes, I'd say continue doing parasite programs. I'm sure you're talking about parasite programs.
Yes, you should continue that pre and post surgery.
Um, not sure if we'll speed chemo or radiation if they take the whole bladder out. That's the surgery. This person's considering that that was mentioned.
We'd rather clean up microscopic cancers at other way possible. Yes. I would agree that that is good to do. We already are doing it. So you are already running the right.
We've done the cancer frequencies for your cancer. This goes to anybody with any type of cancer. If you're going to do surgery, you continue to run your right on a daily basis as much as possible to clean up any microscopic.
Cancer's that are not seen on a PET scan. So even a person who's taken the people make they do a PET scan, everything's clean. They think they have no cancer cells.
Not realizing that you're, you know, the PET scans are only going to pick up masses cancer masses that are over three million cells large. So a person could have a cancer that's 250,000 cells large.
You may, right? No, it's really teeny microscopic and it's not seen, but it's a lot of cells. So using the right program even after the ball key of surgery or even after chemo and even after you find out you have a complete, quote unquote, clean mill of health from the oncologist, understand that there's people that have never had a diagnosis of cancer, but they have cancer growing inside of them.
You've got to be constantly treating.
Do you have any post surgical protocols that you'd recommend either for healing or in place of chemo and radiation.
So as far as in place of chemo and radiation, again, you're doing everything to try to, you know, substitute basically from a natural perspective, chemo and radiation. So there's anything different that we would do there.
But are there some post and pre surgical protocols. Yes, there are. So this is, I just copied the blog post are you having surgery. Here's a natural approach that may help you with recovery. This is just right off our standard website.
So remember always to go to our website and search for some things like this that may already be on there. I've already created a blog post about that. So just go and help yourself to that information right on our blog that will be the most helpful.
Do you test for Lyme disease via specific test. So there are multiple Lyme disease tests out there. I like this DNA connections test because it does test for the DNA microscopic
Lyme and I think it test for 13 colon infections as well. And it just gives you a nice easy to read plus or positive or negative.
With, if you've ever had Lyme, no, the negative amount is it just says if you've ever had Lyme, it doesn't tell you what phase of Lyme you're in. It doesn't tell you how bad your Lyme is. It doesn't give you a qualitative data about, you know,
how sick a person could be from Lyme disease doesn't give you any of that information. It also doesn't give you any progress. There aren't any tests for measuring progress with a treatment of Lyme.
So if somebody's going to go through a natural care protocol or a medical care protocol with maybe antibiotics for Lyme disease, you can't retest and measure. Oh, I'm better because of this test. That just doesn't exist anywhere out there. So that's not even available.
I'll tell you what, you know, we have patients that have Lyme disease there.
How they measure success is they're feeling because most people are only seeking care for Lyme disease because they they have signs and symptoms.
So they're guarding their guiding their care by their symptoms, you know, their brain fog is decreasing or whatever they're looking at. That's what they're looking at.
So this does test for the earlier burglarty, which is the main bacteria and Lyme disease of 13 and its co-infections.
The second part of this question is do protocols on the right. So there's, there's protocols on the right.
For Lyme, we don't recommend doing Lyme disease overnight sets. I would highly recommend you stick with your cancer frequencies.
You can run some of the Lyme sense on daytime sets. And I think this next question talks about that same thing.
I've heard people do the foot bath for Lyme disease. I would say yes, that's a nice way to get the frequencies in is through the foot bath because it's you can it's a milder way to help kill.
The negative thing about killing Lyme, if a person has a really bad Lyme issue, is that Lyme that the organography, the rally of organography has.
That's a gram negative bacteria and gram negative bacteria have a chemical in the cell membrane that can fire and immune response really bad and these people can get really bad.
And it works in our reaction so we got to be careful not too many kill programs for too long in a time with Lyme disease so using the foot bath, it's milder way to deal with it.
So it could be much more beneficial.
So if we have anybody that purchases a knife from us and has product Lyme.
just they start just with different programs
because they don't want them to crash
or with herxander rate action.
Our C-E-A, the markers rising C-E-A markers
for larvae, this person has a C-A-1.
So a C-E-A test to get is a tumor marker test.
There's this person, C-A-1, 25.
That's a third tumor marker test was normal on 826.
And was normal on 112.
So the C-A-1, 25 is not rising,
but the C-E-A was 15.6 in August in 26.4 in November.
So that's rising.
So yes, it's alarming, but you have to weigh it out
with other things too.
So are there things that can skew a tumor marker test?
Yes, what are they?
Well, the most we've spoken about this multiple times,
if you do the do chemotherapy,
that can skew your tumor marker tests.
But there's other things that are not known
that can skew your tumor marker test.
Now, if the C-E-A, like nearly doubled here in a couple of months,
then that should raise a rent's like,
you should weigh it out though with other objective tests
and subjective markers.
So do I feel the same?
Have I feeling better?
Is my fatigue worse?
Have I had this person has colorectal cancer,
I believe, am I having any bleeding?
And I have it any other symptoms?
And my novel was changed.
You got to weigh that out between all those things.
And again, blood tests give you clues.
So it doesn't, this doesn't mean the cancer is growing,
but it's giving you a clue.
Is the cancer growing?
Is this something I need to look at?
Is there something?
Yeah, that might mean.
I might want to do some other investigation.
When was the last CT scanner MRI I had done?
When was it, you know, if I had R by,
he would go with numbers crashing,
R by, if I hademic, you know,
are those R by other CBC numbers crashing?
So you've got to weigh it out between other things too.
So you don't just look at one test,
and you don't just look at objective tests,
you look at subjective tests as well.
What do high B12 blood markers indicate?
Really the answer is nothing.
So almost anybody taking B12 will show high blood B12 markers.
The problem with B12 is it's hard often to get B12
into the cells.
So when you're taking B12, you'll show a lot,
you'll show high elevated B12 in the blood.
There's no harm, no follow with that.
There's no pathologic.
That's not a pathological sign of anything.
So the answer is really you can just completely ignore that.
So if a person is not taking B12
and they have elevated B12,
it can be a sign that they have a need for B12.
What does it make sense?
Well, it actually does because you're not,
it's more difficult to get B12.
So you're getting B12 from your food,
from your meat, from different vegetables
and things have B12 in it.
And if you're have elevated blood B12,
that can be a sign that it's even more difficult
to get B12 into the cells.
Therefore, you might actually need to substitute
the supplement B12 as well, kind of an odd thing,
but that's the truth.
So, but typically have high B12, this is ignore there.
It's not an issue.
A person can have B12 in theemia
and have elevated B12 blood B12, not nervous.
What's a normal vitamin D level for those with cancer?
If you look on the, if you look on the blood tests,
you'll see normal vitamin B12, depends on what the lab,
some will say 30 to 50 is normal,
some will say 30 to 60, some will say 30 to 80 is normal.
And then if your blood vitamin D levels are 112,
people think that's really elevated,
your doctor might actually freak out a little bit,
but in truth, you really want your vitamin D levels
between 60 and 150 if you have cancer.
So, vitamin D can be a great T regulator.
It can help with the immune stimulation
and balance inclination.
So, yeah, if your vitamin D is over 150,
you should probably back off on your vitamin D supplementation.
I really would like to see a person's vitamin D
between 60 and 150.
If it's over 150,
never vitamin D is fat soluble, nutrient,
you don't need to necessarily take it on a daily basis.
Especially if you're over 150, you should drop it down
to maybe once a week.
But if you're at 90,
I would just keep taking the dose that you're taking.
Okay, what about multiple foot baths the same day?
I think it's quite back to this question too.
Yes, you just want to watch for herxibar reaction
like you feel sick afterwards or really sluggish
or your fatigue goes way up.
That could be a herxibar reaction from live disease.
I thought I said this question in this morning.
So, disregard if you find it later.
We are purchasing a second rite with the,
and the true rite rep said,
we should also get the jackhammer amplification.
What do you think about that?
Well, that's a really good question.
So true rite came out.
I want to begin in this year with this jackhammer amplification,
piece that connects to your hammer bulb
and then connects to the machine.
It will increase the, amplify the force
that is going out from the hammer tube
and it will enable you for the hammer tube
to be farther away from you and get the same benefit.
That's the whole idea of that.
So, let's say if the person doesn't like snuggling
with the bulb at night,
or whatever reason, they can't snuggle with it.
And they want to put it,
maybe they have a king size bed
and they want to set the bulb three feet away
from them under the covers.
Well, you're not going to get as much benefit from it.
But if you had the jackhammer amplification piece
of the rife,
but you can get that directly from true rife,
then you could have it farther away from you.
But to me, if you're going to snuggle with the bulb,
more power, really,
I mean, you just need these frequencies
to go through you anyhow.
So, more power, what do we care if you go through the wall
behind your bedroom and out to the yard?
I mean, that's not the point.
So, that, I'm just saying, my opinion is that
the more power, you know, it's more power,
the power that's going on.
So, amplification is the power of the frequencies
to penetrate a person's body.
That's what amperes are in electricity,
is the power of what to push it through.
You only need it to go through your body.
You don't need it to go through the adjacent wall.
But here's another use of the jackhammer would be
to, well, I run it during the day
and I don't want to,
I can't always hold the bulb next to me.
It's sitting on my desk next to me.
Well, then that would be a proper use of the jackhammer.
Well, then I can keep it two to three feet away from me
and get the same benefit as if I was stuggling with it.
Does that make sense?
Again, I only need as much power
to go through my body.
It's plenty powerful to go through your body.
This is where like some of the other rife companies,
like I'll tell you right now,
the GB 4000 is more powerful than the true rife.
It's got more payups.
But again, you only need enough power
for it to go through your body.
Anything else is just wasted.
Well, I want to use it during the day
and I don't want to be right next to it.
Okay, well, then that makes sense.
Then go ahead and use,
and that's really why the GB 4000 has more power
because it's not meant to use it like it would be terribly
cumbersome to use it, right?
It's almost impossible to use the GB 4000 at night.
So if you have the bulb on your lap, that's close enough.
There's no need for the jackhammer.
But I love what true rife is to do.
This is why I love true rife so much
because they're constantly trying to innovate.
They're constantly trying to add new things
that could benefit people in different ways.
So, I mean, that's why I'm such a fan of theirs.
I have no financial stake in that company whatsoever
and I boast on them constantly
because I just see how it's changed so many people's lives.
So it's not a magic one,
but it can make just some fantastic changes.
So yeah, if you're gonna use the jackhammer,
if you're gonna use the rife more during the day
and you're gonna be more farther and distance away
from the bulb, then using a jackhammer makes sense
or if there's some weird application like where you can't
or you just flail around
and you can't keep it next to you,
then the jackhammer makes sense
or if it's a child where you have it zip tied to their crib
and there are three feet away
then the jackhammer totally makes sense in that situation.
That's why you haven't heard me really talk about the jackhammer
very often because those are kind of oddities,
but if you kind of fit into that,
then the jackhammer makes perfect sense to add to it.
I think it's not that expensive.
I think it's a couple of hundred bucks to add that.
So if you think,
well, that would be a nice application, then yes.
But my opinion is if you're struggling,
if you're using the rife the way I have told you to use it,
you're struggling with it at night
adding the jackhammer,
doesn't add any greater benefit to what you're only doing.
All right.
I'm new to sending my Zoom questions on the website.
I just sent some questions in the library that they were received.
So when I look at your questions
and search for questions on the site,
I am doing that up to just a few minutes,
usually before I'll refresh by screen.
And there I see a bunch of questions.
So let's try to add these right down there.
Okay.
So now you can still see my screen, right?
So here's the first one.
Is my type of cancer is it safe to do?
It holds ozone treatments.
And if so, which is beneficial, rectal,
or through the years, through the years?
Well, ozone is a question that's frequently answered.
I do have some answers about ozone on our blog page as well.
I've done a huge fan of ozone for cancer
for multiple reasons.
Ozone is O3 and it's very unstable.
So that's the idea of using ozone.
So you're injecting or you're doing ozone insulation
rectally or through the years to try to get ozone to absorb.
And the idea in the,
when I believe it's misinformation of ozone,
is that you'll read about that people will say that,
oh, it's great because you're getting
all your increasing oxygen.
Well, so oxygen is O2.
It's not O3.
So ozone is O3.
So that's three oxygens bonded.
Oxygen is Ion is a negative two Ion.
So it combines with itself really nice.
It combines with hydrogen really nice
with ozone.
It's an unstable Ion.
And similar to hydrogen peroxide.
So hydrogen peroxide is H2O2.
Versus water, which is H2O,
you have basically an oxygen generating unit
with ozone as well as with hydrogen peroxide.
Well, that's great.
Oxygen is great for cancer, right?
But it's an oxygen Ion.
So it's not an O2.
It's it ends up being an O negative.
So it's a it is a reactive oxygen species.
So that's that is that is dangerous.
So you can search search reactive oxygen species.
And you can see that is can damage DNA
if it's if it's in the cell itself,
it can damage the cell membrane.
It can actually cause cancer.
Well, why would anybody use it?
Well, the the great thing of it is
is that O3 O negative is is searching for something
to attach to.
So if it attaches to your cell membranes,
it could damage the cell membranes.
If it's inside the cell and it attaches to the DNA,
it could damage your DNA.
It could actually cause cancer.
Well, then why would anybody use it?
Because it also could attach to.
Bacteria and fungus and mold.
So it attaches to living things.
So that is actually good.
So ozone actually is produced in our environment.
It is storm.
It's produced with light need and you could go outside
and you could smell that freshness in the air.
That's the ozone that you smell outside.
That's God's way.
I'm actually helping clean up the environment
because that ozone will be unstable.
O3 is unstable.
It'll give off one of the oxygens
and it tends to give it off to living things like mold
and fungus and it helps balance nature
by killing off any bad pathogens in nature.
That's how it works.
So why would you use ozone to be the best use
of ozone as that with cancer?
But it's with biotoxins.
So you have biotoxin illness like like lime.
That's where ozone can be beneficial.
So ozone, topically, can be beneficial.
It's like in dental work.
So a biological dentist will use ozone
in the tooth that he extracts.
Will use ozone to help with any hidden bacteria
under the gum line.
They can ozoneate your gums.
So there's benefits to ozone that way.
If I had your infections, you could use ozone.
You could use hydrogen peroxide.
Lettings you use hydrogen peroxide.
Everybody has that at home,
but it's $3 for a bottle of it.
Why would you use hydrogen peroxide
as a topical antiseptic?
Because hydrogen peroxide leaves you
with an oxygen negative.
Because it's going to fall to the more stable.
It's going to move to this more stable water.
And it will leave you with a negative
that then this old negative will attach to bacteria
and kill any bacteria or anything else on your skin.
So you use hydrogen peroxide as a topical antiseptic.
That's how it works as an antiseptic.
Well, ozone could be used as a topical antiseptic too,
except for the fact that you can't do that
because ozone is a gas,
where hydrogen peroxide isn't liquid.
Well, couldn't I just spray ozone, right?
Gas right onto a topical wound.
Yes, you could, but it's going to, it's a gas
and it's not necessarily going to stay on that wound.
It breathed it in.
You could damage your lungs with excess ozone
and then you could have problems.
Why would excess ozone damage your lungs?
Because it's going to give off a free radical,
own, own negative molecule that can damage cells.
So that's my scoop but ozone.
So can you use home ozone treatments?
Correctly you care.
Does that make sense for colon cancer?
Yeah, maybe, maybe a topical ozone on a cancer
could be beneficial to help kill it.
Maybe would you use it in the ears?
I don't think so, no.
Would you use it for breast cancer?
No, I don't think so.
I just, I wouldn't.
So I do have an article about hydrogen peroxide
at ozone on my blog as well.
Okay, next question.
So to answer the question that came in on the chat was,
yeah, please try to get these in at least a half hour.
So before I was in call and I see some of you did
and I just didn't see it.
So I received my genetic testing.
It was weathered if I still take the recommended supplements
given to me before the genetic test results.
So yeah, so the result, the supplements
that you're were adding from the genetic result
are what we're adding.
So it isn't a subtraction.
So no, these are just additions.
Next question, yes, right?
The RGCC test results came back.
I circulated into the cell was 3.8.
It shows anything greater than five is an issue.
I was told I'm in the very early stages.
What exactly does this mean?
Is this stage one or stage two?
I don't know that I really understand this.
So the RGCC test is not a staging test.
So you can't use RGCC as a way to test your stage.
It doesn't give you a stage of cancer.
Stage E is very specific based on biopsy,
based on CT scan and scan.
So you can't use RGCC for that.
Circulating to the cell of 3.8,
even though that's in the low range,
it's still concerning you want it to be zero
and you want it to stay at zero.
But I've said over and over again,
even if you're at zero doesn't mean
you still don't continue to do treatment
because again, that's just a sample of your blood
at one point in time.
And just like any other tests,
it's just one test you have to balance any objective test
with other objective tests
and with subjective planning to balance it all out.
Next question.
Oh, my MTHFR in the genetic test was highlighted.
But to see 677 was highlighted,
can you explain what that means?
So the MTHFR reductase gene is a very coverage
that's looked at with any genetic testing.
It tells you that if you have especially a double allele defect,
especially on the 677,
you have probably a more difficult time
converting folate into the methyde impact way,
the first thing that most people want to do
that look at genetics is to give that person
methylated supplements like methylated B12
or most commonly they give them
methyl tetrahedral folate.
And I think that's even if you don't have a diagnosis
of cancer, that's a very run thing to do
because remember, even if you have genetic defects,
doesn't mean the genes are okay to work properly.
It means that you have a greater chance
that they're not working properly,
that you have a greater chance of issues
with whatever that gene produces.
Problem by just jumping on one gene and looking at MTHFR
and giving a person methylated supplements
is that will push heavily, push a different pathway
that's called the biopterid pathway.
And you have to look at the biopterid pathway
and defects of that because that could cause major upset
with the retransmitter production
and major upset with all sorts of mood disorder issues.
Secondly, we don't want our cancer patients
taking a ton of methylated supplements
though some is beneficial,
especially if you have issues
with some other blood tests in your CDC.
But we don't typically give a lot of methylated supplements
because it can effectively turn off tumor suppressor genes.
So if we didn't highlight it,
it's something that we don't want you to address.
That's, so we highlight something
that we think is important specifically for you.
Just what is on your genetics,
it's something that we want to address.
All right, next question.
My pH is always acidic by due greens all day
than my pH stays where it needs to be
because there's something else that's going on
that's causing me to be acidic.
So I'm assuming that you're measuring your acid
through your urinary pH or your salivary pH.
And I write about this in my book
and I've said this lots of times
that our Zoom calls that I don't take any credence
in measuring salivary and urinary pH.
So all salivary and urinary pH tells you
is the pH of your saliva or your urine.
It doesn't tell us what our systemic pH is.
So understand in your body, you have buffering systems.
In your blood, your blood pH will stow at 7.4 ish.
Like maybe I think normal blood pH is 7.435
or something like that.
If it goes to 7.2, you're gonna be more acidic.
You're like those to 7.6, you're more alkaline.
Either one is just as dangerous.
You could die.
So your body won't allow that
except in late stage early death
that you could have a change in blood pH.
So your body has buffering systems to buffer that.
So if your body uses minerals to buffer your pH,
your body uses hydrochloric acid to buffer your pH.
Your hydrochloric acid production, your stomach
has a lot to do with sodium bicarbonate production
that also both of them buffer your pH.
So when a person when you read a book about you need to,
cancer is frozen in acidic environment
and you need to alkalize yourself,
there's truth to that statement.
How do you alkalize yourself?
You alkalize yourself by changing your diet,
getting off a bunch of processed foods,
start eating better, start taking care of yourself,
you're eating more greens, you're eating more salads,
you're taking green drinks, you're doing things
like that they're all alkalizing to your tissues.
Great, how do you measure that?
You want to know the truth?
You can't.
Your pH of your saliva and your pH of your urine
is completely unrelated to the pH of your cancer.
To the pH of your cancer.
Completely.
So if you could imagine that make your pH of your urine
really alkaline and it stayed alkaline
that does not mean the pH around your cancer
or the pH of your body systemically is alkaline.
It just doesn't, it's not measurable.
It just doesn't work that way, that's wrong physiology.
And the books that have come out and talked about that
are not understated physiology.
Matter of fact, there's different online nature
of toxic causes that push pH as their main way to measure
a person's health and it makes zero sense physiologically.
These people are not understated physiology.
This is my big pet peeve against quote unquote natural
practitioners is that sometimes the things
that they're pushing and recommending are just wrong
and it makes natural practitioners look bad
in the scientific community because it's incorrect physiology.
So it's the same thing if I got to start drinking alkaline water
because that's going to make me healthy.
Well, your pH has a stomach.
Your stomach has a pH of about 2.5
and you're drinking alkaline water at 8.5 pH.
All you're doing is alkalizing your stomach.
You can actually cause more ill health
because if your pH of your stomach isn't at 2.5-ish,
then you're not going to properly digest your carbohydrates.
You're going to have carbohydrates and proteins
go into your small attested as a bolus
that's less than properly digested to say the least.
And it's going to cause gut issues
and all sorts of problems in your absorption rate
of your nutrients is going to go down
and it's going to cause major problems
that I speak highly about.
And often about the health of your gut
can be the first place where any disease
including cancer can begin with
and it often begins with a decreased hydrochloric acid
in your stomach.
So we have to, I'm not trying to insult anybody
and if you're really stuck on pH of your saliva
and your urine and you want to keep doing that,
then by all means you can do that.
I'm just here to share my opinion.
It makes no sense physiologically.
If I take a whole bunch of minerals,
I will probably dump excess minerals into my urine
in my pH of my urine is going to become more alkaline.
My pH will go up in my urine.
That does has nothing to do with acidity
or lack there of my cancer itself.
Cancer because it's highly metabolic.
It's going to give a lot more waste out
and that waste is going to be more acidic.
That's what waste is
and that's going to be your cancer
is going to have a higher acidity at the cancer.
But it's not because cancer grows at a spot
where it's higher acidity.
It's because cancer is growing
and highly metabolic give it off a lot of waste.
Therefore it's causing this acidic slime layer around it.
That's the problem.
So I think it's wise to be drinking green drinks.
I think it is.
But if your purpose of drinking tons of green drinks
is solely to get your pH down
and I think that's a wrong marker on that.
So hate me if you want to, but that's okay.
Another question.
Sentimental is so pure.
I have used ozone and foreign friends soda.
So understand.
So there are ozone sodas where you go into this capsule
and your head is exposed and the capsule is a soda.
It's increasing the temperature.
So acting like a zip up soda or anything.
And then it's using ozone too.
Do I think there's a benefit of doing that?
Well, the only benefit that I see of that with ozone
on your skin is if you have skin issues
that you're trying to kill things on your skin.
You have to remember though that your skin also has
a flora or a microbiotic as well.
So there's a lot more information coming about
about microbiotic.
So your microbiota of your gut,
I think everybody's heard of that.
And that's why you take probiotics and prebiotics
and postbiotics is because you're trying to keep
the balance of your microbiota in your gut.
Well, that's great.
But you have a microbiota in your mouth.
You have a microbiota in your cytosys
and your nasal cavity of a microbiota in your lungs.
You have a microbiota and it's different
in those different areas.
You have a microbiota in your eyes.
You have a microbiota on your skin.
So we don't want to kill off the microbiota.
But I guess if I had a fungal infection on my skin,
like tonal infection or something like that,
then I can see using ozone sodas for that reason.
So I was approached years ago with these ozone sodas
came out of them and we were seeing people in the clinic.
I told them to be great,
but then you start to think about it.
You go physiologically,
you're not going to be sure about it, you pose.
I mean, why would you do it?
Would you do it to kill off something on your skin?
Well, you know, let it kill off.
It makes sense to understand you think through these things
from a physiological perspective,
just try to walk through the thought process of this.
And then I, you know, we asked these companies,
what's the benefit of this?
Well, you get oxygen to your skin as well.
And you know, that doesn't make any sense.
You give me wrong information.
Tent is, you show me studies that show that.
There's just making sense physiologically.
So it says, I think it caused terrible die-off
I've been sick for a couple of weeks.
Now, I don't think it had,
if this, you know, you're saying what happened
to you caused terrible die-off in sick for a couple of weeks,
I don't think it had to do with ozone.
If, if the, if you were reading the ozone,
you could, it could cause this.
And you could be sick for a couple of weeks
because you could damage your lungs.
You could damage your alveolar epithelial cells
with ozone to be very careful with that.
And I have not done ozone or infrared sense that.
I don't, I mean, the infrared sauna,
I don't think that was it.
Only the right, I started act puncture last week.
And I am slowly getting better.
We think this is normal to be sick for 21 days though.
Oh, it's never normal to be sick for 21 days.
And all I do know that the spike protein issues,
I don't know if you have been vaccinated,
but I am very, very highly opposed to this vaccine
that's out right now.
And I think if you aren't getting vaccinated
or have been vaccinated, if anybody has done this call,
that is, it was a horrible mistake.
I think the spike proteins are very damaging.
And if you're around people that have been vaccinated,
that you're going to look at that issue too
because spike proteins are not good for exposure for you too.
So it could be unrelated to the ozone and infrared sauna
I doubt if it was the infrared sauna, but don't fact.
So I will again, but I probably shall be
forgetting the one of them right now,
based upon your experience.
Okay, questions on the chat.
Okay, for my upcoming surgery,
there's a likelihood that I will need a blood transfusion.
I'm concerned that what I will be exposed to in the blood
is vaccinations by proteins that I have not myself chosen to take.
Yeah, every state is different.
I know that Ann was trying to get unvaccinated blood
or a direct transfusion because she had the same blood type
as her son and they wouldn't allow it
and they wouldn't, she could not get a guarantee
that it was a vaccinated blood and they just had a proceed.
So I would ask, that's the thing, just ask.
I switched to a vegetarian diet and also I eat eggs.
Should I stop taking B12s?
Should I stop taking B12 supplement?
No, I would not.
Even with an elevated B12 again, like I said,
I would still take B12 especially if you're on a vegetarian diet.
If you are eating eggs, there's B12 in the eggs,
but I would still be taking B12.
The ICEA numbers increase from 5.5 to 15.6 in one year.
So my cancer protocol was updated one month later,
my CES continue to increase.
No, I would not say to update it.
I would test it again because it takes time for things to change
and we may need to be considered at least doing some standards of care as well.
And if you just jumped on this call,
I did answer that question or your other questions earlier.
So make sure you listen to the call once I get it posted again.
Seems like what I started with,
Esther, clear I have had having night sweats and body water
has been terrible to better want to take you three a day.
Sorry, but that's a sign that it's actually more female.
So, sorry, but astro clear,
the purpose of that is to help pull estrogens out of your body
and most people don't get signs of that symptoms.
But actually, if you do, that's actually a good sign
that it works better for you.
The natural aromatase inhibitors,
like Esther, clear and dim and calcium degluterate
and the different ligaments and such that we're using for natural aromatase inhibitors,
the negative is they don't work as good as medical drug aromatase inhibitors.
But those have horrible side effects much worse than just the night sweats and body water.
So it's but you could decrease the dose you can play with it
and it would try to produce that effect through an answer leads.
Oh, I've not been vaccinated but caught the cold from a grandson.
OK, we think it was shedding of some of vaccine.
Yep, that's very possible.
That's a response for your 20-month day sickness.
Some people are much more sensitive to the spike proteins.
I am particularly more sensitive.
I think my life is too.
It's hard to get around that.
And I apologize if you're on this call, if you're offended
because you got vaccinated, but again, you're asking about opinion.
So you're just going to have to try your best to stay away from those things.
Think about adding more fiber to your diet that could help go back to the detox course
and look at phase six of the detox phase five binders of adding some charcoal or the favorite
binders are clear by their or a phase six assist because it adds charcoal and full of
acid and some other things.
Can you talk about options with the breast to remind us two inches by three inches?
Is this too large for black sand?
Are there other options?
So yeah, it's too technically for black sand.
You're really putting on a dime size spot of black sand and the breast tumor has to be open.
If it's just near the surface, you have a ball jutter there and it's maybe a palpable
lump, you can't use black sand.
There are saves that can draw it out to the surface and bring it out to the surface and
open up the skin and give you an open wound.
But that's a whole other ball of waxed out.
We've had patients that have real good success with using black sand and open wood tumors,
whether it's a breast tumor or something else, but there's some huge negatives too.
So we've had people it didn't work well and they've done it, you know, dozens and dozens
of times and it continues to draw and it just is not digging deep enough to really make
a difference.
So there's negatives too.
Why doesn't the oncologist want it to come to the surface?
And it's really for that reason is that when it does open to an open wound, now you're
dealing with having to deal with an open wound and dressing the wound and there's positives
that you could use different topicals on it but there's huge negatives too.
So from the oncologist standpoint, it might be best to use chemotherapy before it breaks
through the skin because then you're not having to heal that skin and it's good to have
the multitude of counselors or talk to the oncologist about, about doing it.
Understand with all our patients, all our members, we have lots of people that have done standards
of care alongside everything they're doing here and have had phenomenal results.
So we have breast cancer members that have been with us for 15 years and they haven't done
any standards of care, but we've had breast cancer members with been with us for 15 years
and have done some standards of care too.
So it's a decision you have to make, but I think that when you pray about it and you really
feel like God's leading you in that direction, don't feel like you've failed or something
like that because you're going to do some chemo or something, goodness sakes, don't let anybody
push you either direction and don't let your conscience make you feel bad about something
too.
God never, the Holy Spirit doesn't speak to that way and shame you.
So if you feel shamed or anything like that, know that that's coming from the enemy.
Also between the tumor on my breast, above the nipple and nipple, there is a little bit of
crusty flakes.
That's common with different types of breast cancers too.
A notice the tumor has been changing, seems like they be coming closer to the surface, seems
to be a bit more bruising, looking very sore.
So with any breast cancer, it's better than it's coming closer to the surface than it's
going back towards the chest wall.
But again, breaking through the skin, that opens up a whole pan door of ox and other positives
and negatives.
So the oncologists in one sense, they gave them food serum would have to say, well, it's a
much better thing than it's coming out instead of going back towards chest wall.
But in their opinion, they only have what they have to treat it.
Now, let's say that's wrong, maybe using chemo now would be the best thing to do.
So just consider that.
Okay, so I think I got through everybody's question that just sent in on real recently here.
So it is trying to get those questions in at least an hour before the zoom call.
So I have time to get it uploaded to our little PowerPoint here that would be best if you
can't, that's okay.
We'll get to it on the next zoom call.
So you could ask it.
So that's okay, too.
But we just need to start holding fast and we've given a lot of leeway to people who were
used to sending in questions via email.
We just can't legally do that anymore.
So we have to use the member site through questions and we have to answer them on a zoom call
like this to keep us legally safe.
It's just the attacks that we're getting from the power step B. It just is what it is in
the world that we live in.
I want to keep helping people.
So if you're used to sending in questions, you're going to get an email back saying, please
we'll answer this on the zoom call and everybody on the zoom call does they have an issue with
it.
It's people that are not in zoom call.
So get more people out here and that will be so much better.
Thank you for praying for AJ.
He is doing better.
That's Ann's son with leukemia.
It's very touching go there.
He actually got to go home using the hospital for a little bit.
So thank you just got to go home on Friday or Saturday.
So that's exciting.
So thanks for your prayers.
We know that we're going to be constantly praying for you guys as well and we cherish your
prayers.
So with that, we're going to do and we'll see you on Wednesday.
So that I love all of you that are praying for you and let's get a couple of days.